let's talk about
the virtue of money
and the brokenness of those guys out
there
a lot of experts out there on the
internet all you need is an internet
connection and a few thousand followers
you can buy on fiverr and you too can be
an internet
but still be broke right um there's a
lot of guys out there that deceive with
virtues
i made a few notes here rented lambo
maybe
guy puts a raptor grill on a f-150 and
isn't driving a raptor but he wants to
hold out to the world that he's a big
badass
okay there's lots of guys out there that
don't have a pot to piss in or a window
to throw it out of
that will deceive you with virtues and
stories they're often
the number one guy which is of course
also the liar too
so you have to be attentive if
somebody's 20 years old they're young
i just got off a call with a guy a few
hours ago they're young and they don't
have much to show for their life fine
do they have ambition is my first
question do they have a plan
women have a lot of patience for young
guys that are 20 with a plan you're an
alpha dude you're 20 and you have a plan
you're good to go you're 40.
doesn't have as much patience for you my
friend
you have to get your money right the
sooner the better
if you're in a comfort zone where you're
looking at yeah well
i make uh you know two thousand dollars
a month that's pretty good money for a
guy my age i'm only 19 years old
okay it's a starting point i also know
guys that make two thousand dollars a
day that are 19 years old
right your limiting belief is gonna
hold you to where it is that you believe
that you should be
avoid those people that
are broke you hang out with five
broke people that have made some bad
choices that resulted in their
brokenness you will be the sixth
i guarantee it guarantee it
just like i guarantee the sun will rise
tomorrow it will happen
any one of these people if you invite
into your life they're going to
overflow into yours okay
so be attentive to what people do with
their financial resources
a lot of people say oh you know i made
uh 200 000
last year i made half a million i made a
million dollars last year
but at the end of the day you can make
two hundred thousand dollars and have
expenses beyond that
you're still broke doesn't matter
make five hundred thousand you spend
five hundred one thousand you're still
broke
doesn't matter you don't know how to
manage your money matt like money is
the simplest thing for anybody to grasp
it's a math equation
that's all it is you make two thousand
dollars a month you spend less than two
thousand dollars a month you set aside
money for a rainy day fund it's pretty
simple
ideally if you're a high income earner
you should be setting aside
a lot more and having zero debt and
having investments in diversifications
in all different areas but i see
far too many guys i talked to a lot of
guys guys you know it's been it's been
well over a thousand now easily
and there's been a lot of these men that
have invited
it's it's either in the form of a woman
that brings financial
problems into their life or it's
somebody that they get into business
with
and i'm not sure what's worse because
i've seen both do a huge number
on guys financial future
wealth you know the family nest egg
how do you spot broke people i guess is
the next question
you watch them it's as simple as that
they're going to say things that are not
going to be aligned
with their actual behaviors i'm a
big awesome successful entrepreneur blah
blah blah
i run multiple businesses and venues and
events
but they rent a house with a family
member and they don't own a car and they
have to rent a vehicle
if somebody comes into town just watch
their behavior
it's going to tell on them over time you
should
always be assessing somebody
when you consider letting them into your
inner circle i always tell you guys you
have to draw a perimeter
okay there's a perimeter us versus them
the guys on the us the guys on the
inside
okay the five people that you spend the
most time with
those are the guys in your inner
perimeter
that's perhaps the significant other or
significant others whatever it is you're
doing
but on that inner perimeter are the
people that you have to be very very
careful about letting into your inner
circle
anybody that is on the outside of that
that's trying to get on the inside
you should be evaluated you should be
evaluating if they're liars if they're
it
you know if they got vices if they're
into drugs if they have money issues
if you're gonna get involved with a
woman or if you're gonna get involved
with a business partner invite them to
your inner circle that bring these
problems to the table i guarantee it's
gonna be problematic i knew a guy in my
20s
even early 30s i let him hang around for
that long
that almost embodied all of these
components here that i'm talking about
and i'll tell you my life improved
dramatically
when i deep six them when i got rid of
you gotta get rid of them all right
you